bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de shengxiao mis le fabricant chinois
qui arrivent en france très très très
très bientôt
au mois de mai donc vraiment arriver
très rapidement
justement après le chiot me parce qu'ils
vont lancer un nouveau produit haut de
gamme qui est le mif 7 et on en parle
alors si on me c'est vraiment la marque
qui monte la marque qui monte de plus en
plus les produits sont hyper cool hyper
séduisant pas cher vraiment pas cher
mais par contre la qualité est au rendez
vous l'idée de shiomi dès le départ
c'est vraiment de créer des smartphones
pas cher qui vont concurrencer les plus
chers les produits haut de gamme avec
vraiment des prix défiant toute
concurrence voilà ça c'est dit c'est
clair tapis les produits sont
performants et ils sont super pas cher
donc on a deux gammes qui sont vraiment
top
la ganne mimix la gamine x2 est cette
annonce et ya pas très longtemps et là
la gamme me avec un missel qui devrait
arriver d'ici très peu de temps
c'est un produit qui devrait être
dévoilée fin mai le 23 mai très
précisément
alors à quoi va ressembler ce produit
qu'est ce qu'il y aura dans le ventre
voilà les infos qu'on a tout de suite on
devrait avoir un écran borderless un
écran oled de 5,65 pouces avec une
résolution de 2880 par 1440 pixels une
encoche une encoche qui va arriver sur
ce produit tout en haut
on devrait retrouver côté puissance à sa
dragonne 845 soit 6 jega dans l'âme soit
8 gigas de ram une batterie de 3170 mis
en péril une surcouche mi-8 9 qui
tournerait sur un android 8.0 oreo on
aurait un double capteur photo à
l'arrière une caméra photo à l'avant pas
plus d'infos là dessus en tout cas ce
qui est très intéressant c'est qu'à
l'avant on pourrait avoir une
reconnaissance en trois dimensions comme
fayçal dit c'est à dire une caméra un
capteur infrarouge quelques affaires un
mapping complet de votre visage en trois
dimensions pour déverrouiller avec votre
visage c'est comme fait c'est dit on
n'est pas comme le facebook de samsung
qui reconnaît votre image qui
déverrouille mais c'est pas hyper
sécurisé fait saïdi quand même beaucoup
plus sécurisée et là pour le coup ça
pourrait être vraiment intéressant sur
un produit haut de gamme vraiment pas
cher autre point intéressant on pourrait
avoir un lecteur d'empreintes digitales
directement intégré à l'écran on le
retrouve aujourd'hui chez d'autres
constructeurs chinois et lecteur
d'empreinte digitale intégrée à l'écran
ça peut être très intéressant à l'heure
après là ça pourrait faire un peu
doublon avec la reconnaissance de visage
en trois dimensions à voir est ce qu'ils
veulent vraiment dire nous on est tous
comme ça on a le full option est le
produit le plus sexy vous avez soit
dérouillage directement sur l'écran soit
la reconnaissance faciale c'est au choix
de toute façon c'est haut de gamme
vous avez tous donc vous choisissez
directement c'est une possibilité
j'ai du mal vraiment à croire qu'on est
les deux pourquoi pas après on voit
qu'un fabricants comme apple a fait le
choix de ne mettre que fayçal dit de ne
pas mettre de l'étang d'empreintes
digitales ni à l'avant et à l'arrière
là pour le coup je suis venu pour eux de
dire nous on s'en fout on va plus loin
on met les deux comme ça vous avez le
choix
je suis pas sûr heureusement pour
l'instant les rumeurs l'évoquent
vraiment ça pourrait vraiment très
intéressant et on devrait aussi avoir
une recharge sans fil
alors voilà un peu les différentes
rumeurs qu'on a aujourd'hui sur ce
produit sont chiants omis mi7 je sais
j'aurais bien voulu nous en dire plus
sur bellamy en avoir plus pour l'instant
j'y ai rien d'autre sous le coude c'est
vraiment les différentes infos que j'ai
pu glaner mais soyez sûr que dès qu'on
aura davantage d'informations et dé qui
va être présentée surtout on va en
reparler très prochainement alors pour
faire un petit break point son chien au
mix vous assurer que c'est une marque
qui vraiment top j'ai déjà testé
différents produits de xiaomi le minix
deux c'est plus prendre en main au mwc à
barcelone
j'attends le mx 2 es j'espère pour le
prendre en main très rapidement pour
pouvoir vous en parlez vous dire comment
je trouve que c'est vraiment un des
produits haut de gamme de la marque
je vais tester leurs ennemis 5 plus qu'
un produit aussi qui est vraiment très
sympa très bien fait et là j'attends
effectivement semi 7 avec impatience
mais connaissant xiaomi la volonté
d'avoir des produits toujours haut de
gamme d'excellente qualité
on peut être sûr qu'ils vont continuer à
innover continuer à utiliser les maires
technologies du moment pour proposer des
smartphones vraiment pas cher et soyez
sûrs qu'à partir du 22 mai dexia qui va
arriver on va énormément en parler parce
que pour l'instant si vous les voulez
vous êtes obligés de les importer passer
par des sites pour les importer bien
acheter des global jackson pour avoir
quelque chose de compatible sur les
bornes française et les bandes
européenne mais là avec un chiot mis en
france vous allez avoir quelque chose de
beaucoup mieux vous allez pouvoir les
acheter directement sur leurs sites dans
les stores shiomi qui vont arriver
et n'a déjà en espagne va y en avoir en
france et surtout en sav assuré
directement par chien oui donc croyez
moi shiomi on va beaucoup en parallèle
dites moi vous est ce que vous êtes déjà
client de la marque est ce que vous la
trouvez qu est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter
vous marquez tout ça en commentaires
questions suggestions et tout le reste
vous le savez d'ici là je vous invite à
me laisser des jolies pousse à vous
abonner passe comparaître toujours plus
et toujours me doutais que je sois de
smartphones de plein de choses de
tablettes dans
l'inhalateur de robotique et tout ça
tout ça d'ici là soigner sa santé vous
bien
je vous embrasse pour le soin de vous et
à bientôt ciao
[Musique]